thank you for checking out some of our  favorite season one moments season two  kicks off monday and we'll be coming to  you from los angeles all week long and  we have so many surprises in store for  you  should i spoil a couple now  all right  well we're dedicating one day next week  to all things emmy with our friends from  entertainment tonight and this year's  memc cedric the entertainer i know i  love him and kevin and michelle  plus the super talented  billy  ilish is stopping by  she has two number one albums under her  belt at age 19 and just so much more i  mean people wear t-shirts with her this  she means so much to people including me  and i'm really looking forward to  sitting down with her  okay and we'll be back with more  memorable moments and behind the scenes  secrets tomorrow and mark your calendars  for the big season 2 premiere on monday  september 13th i love monday  see you then  [Music]  you